- Okay, everybody, we're gonna
go ahead and get started.
So if you're on the outskirts,
come on into the outskirts.
We're gonna be talking
about using Amazon Nova Act
to simplify login workflows.
Please put your hands together,
give a warm welcome to your speakers,
Anand Srinivas and Floris van der Grinten.
(audience applauds)
- Hey, what's up, folks?
First off, we're super excited.
Thank you very much for coming in.
And we're super excited
to be talking about being
a Nova Act launch partner
and using Amazon Nova Act
to simplify login workflows.
And my name is an Anand Srinivas,
I'm the VP of product
and AI here at 1Password,
and I'm here with Floris van der Grinten,
who's a senior developer
in AI at 1Password as well.
Perfect.
So the thing I want to get
started with is 1Password,
we're pretty well-known
for our security model.
There's actually a 70-page
white paper out there
if anyone wants some bedtime reading
about exactly how that works.
And we recently updated that
security model for agentic AI
and what we think is important.
And so I just want to go
through a couple of these
that are key here.
The first is this idea
that secrets stay secret.
We have a very strict zero knowledge model
where any system hosted by 1Password
cannot decrypt your credentials.
And that's the model
that we intend to keep
with agentic AI as well.
The second and third here,
authorization should be
deterministic, not probabilistic,
and that raw credentials
should never enter
into a model's context,
those have to do with things like MCP.
So, for instance, sending raw credentials
down the MCP channel
is probably not best practice, right?
Is how we look at that.
And so we look for deterministic workflows
to transfer credentials in that way.
And then the rest of the principles
are all around transparency, auditability,
and other aspects of it.
So overall at 1Password,
the way we look at AI in general
is there's a component of this
which is using AI within our products.
And so we might call that AI for security.
And actually, Floris will be
covering that later on today.
And that's exactly how we
use the Nova Act models
to make the 1Password
product better, right?
And so he'll cover that.
The other side of this is security for AI,
which is using 1Password's products
to help secure agentic
AI as they're deployed.
And so that's the part I'm
gonna talk about a little bit
before I hand off to Floris.
But before I do,
what I want to sort of
talk about a little bit
is a sort of taxonomy
that will make this discussion
a little bit more clear
and useful hopefully.
So the way we look at AI
or agentic AI in particular
is on the vertical axis of this,
we classify it into two broad categories.
The first is agentic AIs
that interact with other
applications and services
by clicking around in a web browser
or more generally computer use, right?
They're mimicking a person
in terms of, like, that interaction.
The other type of agentic
AI uses programmatic means.
So think MCP, APIs,
other kinds of standard
approaches that way.
And then on the horizontal axis at the top
is where these agentic AIs are deployed.
Are they deployed on your
device, like, on your laptop,
or are they in the cloud, right?
And so if you look at what
this looks like in practice,
just some examples,
so when a browser-use style agentic AI
is running on your laptop,
examples of this are
things like Perplexity
or OpenAI's Atlas browser, right?
And the use cases here,
you're just automating something
on behalf of yourself, right?
Whereas in the cloud,
now we're talking about Nova Act
plus something like
AgentCore Browser Tool,
where the use cases are,
hey, I don't want to have
to sit in front of my laptop
and run this.
I can run this
asynchronously in the cloud.
It can be automation for myself,
it can be an internal
application for employees,
or it can be a production application
that's deployed in the cloud
that's deployed on behalf
of customers, right?
So any of those use cases.
The other side of this is programmatic.
And so, again, on your laptop,
what this looks like is
something like Cursor, right?
Or Loveable or Claude desktop, right?
And the use cases here are
a lot about vibe coding,
but it's just about automating
and making yourself
more efficient as well.
And then the cloud version of
this are deployed applications
or, you know, applications that are built
through agent builders
or AI that's embedded in,
you know, other applications
like Notion, for example, Notion AI.
And the use cases here,
again, are very similar
to the use cases for
the cloud applications
for browser-use agentic AI as well.
And so what we're gonna
focus on for this talk,
because it's relevant to
Nova Act in particular
and our launch partnership with AWS,
is the first side of this
or the top half of this,
which is around browser-use agentic AI.
But hopefully we'll be back at another day
to talk about the
programmatic AI stuff as well
and how 1Password can help
secure that side of it as well.
So getting into that,
the first one I want to talk about
is remotely deployed
browser-use style agentic AI.
So think about this
as there's a headless browser
running in the cloud, right?
And there's an LLM that's
driving that headless browser.
And basically you can prompt that LLM
and just let it run asynchronously.
And obviously for it to be of any value,
it has to log into things, right?
It has to log into different websites,
access different services,
and so on and so on.
So how do we solve that problem, right,
of getting those
credentials securely filled
on behalf of the agentic AI
without actually giving those
credentials to the agentic AI
into the context window
and also without, you know, a person
having to pause the thing
and manually type it in
and remember their password?
Hopefully we've gotten over
those kind of problems.
And so we recently made an announcement,
we're gonna be making
many more announcements
with partners on this,
where our solution
is we actually have a
1Password browser extension
running inside the headless
browser in the cloud.
And what we're able to do
is when that agentic or that LLM
wants to access some website,
it asks that browser extension,
"Hey, I would like to
fill in this website."
And previously, you
would've actually connected
the service and 1Password, right?
So in this example, we
made an announcement
with a company called Browserbase.
And so you would beforehand
connect Browserbase with 1Password
and sort of that sets it up.
And what happens is in the flow,
the LLM asks the browser extension,
"Can I fill this website?"
The browser extension asks
you, the person, right?
It gives you an auth prompt and says,
"Hey, Browserbase headless browser
is trying to access
this particular website
and wants your credentials for it.
Do you authorize it?"
And so you would approve that flow
and basically the credentials are sent
end-to-end encrypted, right?
Where they're only decrypted
inside the browser extension
that is actually in that headless browser.
And so that's the solution
that we've come up with here
that solves this problem
of, again, filling the
credentials on behalf of the agent
in a secure, encrypted way
without exposing the
credentials to the agent.
And some of the things going
forward that we're working on
are things like asynchronous
workflows, right?
So how do you set policy on the fact
that, okay, well, maybe
I don't want to approve
every single credential.
There's some low-risk ones
that can just go through,
no problem, right?
But maybe some higher risk ones,
I do want like an explicit
human-in-the-loop auth prompt.
And so some of the things
like that we're working on.
But that's an example
of browser-use agentic AI in the cloud,
how we're securing that.
The next part of this is what
about browser-use agentic AI
that is running on your laptop?
How do we secure that?
And so here,
recently we've announced
partnerships with Perplexity
as well as OpenAI's Atlas browser as well.
And we are launch partners with them
and the only security
launch partners with them.
And basically the idea is the
1Password browser extension
can work on these browsers
and so it solves at least the problem
of, again, you're not
manually typing passwords
into these things, right?
You're able to fill it
from your vault, right?
And then going forward,
what we'll be looking to
do is add more automations
to this particular workflow as well.
And so, you know, hopefully
that kind of gives you an idea
that at least on the browser-use side,
that's the breadth of how we're looking
at sort of how to secure agentic AI.
And as I said earlier,
you know, hopefully we'll
be back in the future
to talk about the
programmatic AI stuff as well.
So with that, what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna hand off
to my colleague, Floris,
and he's gonna get into
how we're actually using
the Nova Act models within
the 1Password product
to solve important production use cases.
Floris?
- Cool.
Hi, I'm Floris from the
engineering team at 1Password,
and I'm gonna be showing you
how we're using agentic AI at 1Password
to improve our own product
in a way that just wouldn't
be possible in a pre-AI era.
And the star of the show here
is really Amazon's Nova Act,
which launched here at re:Invent,
and it's their browser-use
agent agentic AI solution.
So let's talk about autofill.
1Password comes with a browser
extension, as you may know.
And this adds a small
icon in login form fields.
And if you click that icon,
you can choose a credential,
the credential that you want
to use to log into the website,
and then 1Password does the
tedious work of logging in
and filling out the form.
So that's how it works today.
But we're working on the next
generation now of autofill
and we're calling it Universal Sign On.
And with Universal Sign On,
we really wanna take the
experience of logging in
from, "Hey, 1Password, fill
in this login form for me,"
to a more holistic, like, "Hey,
1Password, just log me in.
Do whatever it takes to log me in,"
and so regardless of the login method,
so whether that's a username/password,
a TOTP for MFA, enterprise SSO,
a passkey, or sign in
with GitHub or Google,
which you probably
forgot which one you used
for which website again.
And so here's how that looks.
So I click on a website
and it automatically
goes to the login page,
signs me in, enters the
password, enters the TOTP,
and I'm logged in with
just a single click,
hands off the keyboard.
Now, so how does this work?
Unfortunately, there's
not a standard protocol
for logging into websites.
It's free-for-all HTML
with lots of ambiguity.
And for classic autofill,
we have more or less solved the ambiguity
with a one-size-fits-all or a
one-size-fits-most algorithm
that's based on heuristics.
And it's been working great
and it's being used millions
of times per day by many users.
But now for Universal Sign On,
we're running into the
limits of the heuristics
that we can articulate in our code
because now the browser extension,
it wouldn't just need to
know how to fill in the form,
it also needs to know how to navigate to
and through the form,
which is much more complex to do.
So ideally we would have
website-specific logic here
because every website is different.
And to make this a success
and to realize the
Universal Sign On vision,
this is what we're gonna need.
The problem is, though,
as you probably guess,
as you can probably guess,
this doesn't scale if you
have to do this by hand
because, yeah, there are
millions of websites out there
that offer a login, that offer logins.
And also, even if we were to do this,
it's gonna be brittle
because at the scale we'd operate on,
we would see breaking
changes every single day.
So that's not really an option.
So now with Nova Act,
we can finally solve this.
We can scale this up.
So what we've done,
we've built an AI agent using Nova Act
that goes out on the web,
browses these websites for us,
and it gathers the
intelligence that we need
around how different
websites offer logins.
And the intelligence is then
validated by a second agent,
which also uses Nova Act
to validate whether the information
that we get about the login
experience is correct.
And then it gets fed into
what we call the Site Intelligence Engine
and that exposes it to
our browser extension
and the browser extension
then uses the intelligence to
enhance the existing algorithm
for a smooth login experience.
And what's nice about this is
that it can run out of band,
so it can run in our infrastructure
and gather the intelligence
and pass that to the browser extension
so that the browser extension,
the login experience there
will just stay blazingly fast
and also deterministic.
And what's also nice is that
we can run the validation agent
periodically in the background
to see if the intelligence
is still correct or not,
and if not, invalidate it.
So let's have a look at how
the Nova Act agent does this.
So we're gonna have it browse
to the re:Invent website
and the instructions that we give is,
"Find how this website offers login."
And this is a pretty simple example
because there's a big login
button on the top, right?
So it should be able to find it here.
Let's see if, yes, clicked it.
And it's able to find the login form
and it knows this is the login form,
so I'm gonna return.
If we look at a slightly
more complex example,
here is the website for Duolingo.
And this is a bit more difficult
because it doesn't have a
traditional login button.
It just says, it has a button that says,
"I already have an account."
And to make it a bit more complicated,
it's not a standard
button within with an href
that links to the login button,
but it's a JavaScript click handler.
And this would be much more complicated
to build it in a
heuristic-based algorithm.
But for humans, it's easy.
Humans just click, "I
already have an account."
And because Nova Act uses the
same human kind of reasoning,
it's still easily able
to get to the login page,
which is really great.
And along the way, Nova
Act also logs every step
in the evaluation loop that it takes.
And as you can see, it really
thinks like a human here.
It reasons like a human.
So it finds a button that says,
"I already have an account,"
which likely links to the login form,
then it knows, "Okay,
I need to click that,"
and then it actually is
able to perform the click.
And lastly, it will evaluate it again
and then it reasons about,
"Hey, this is the login form,
so I'm done with my task."
So to recap, website-specific intelligence
can meaningfully improve
the 1Password product
in a way that just wouldn't
be possible in a pre-AI era.
And we really just only
scratched the surface
of what agentic AI can do for our product,
but if you want to try it out
and get a glimpse of this new
universal login experience,
you can install the beta
of the 1Password extension,
which already has this new UX
and the first data intelligence
powered by Amazon Nova Act.
So thank you for listening.
- [Anand] We can take
some questions, yeah.
(audience applauds)